well everybody and welcome to another
Python and flash tutorial video in this
video we're gonna be talking about how
we can add the JavaScript plug-in of hi
charts to our Python flask application
so even if you are not too interested in
using maybe high charts specifically
this kind of methodology to how we're
going to interact with this JavaScript
plug-in can be kind of used in other
JavaScript plugins so with that let's go
ahead and get started first of all if
you're not familiar with what high
charts is pull their website we actually
have to download anything from their
website we'll reference their
documentation from our script but this
is their website these are you know
their charts if you're not familiar with
them now you'll probably start
recognizing them like I was saying about
bootstrap you've probably seen charts
that look like this
they're pretty popular charts so anyway
these are the charts if it's always a
good idea to go to the high charts demo
here and look at all the options I've
got all kinds of stuff gauges 3d charge
all kinds of line charge just plenty of
stuff free for you to look at and use so
if you're looking for something very
specific you can kind of port over what
I'm about to show you to do just that so
that's about it I'll need to show you
with how charts also keep in mind hide
sharts is free for any free web
application but if you charge for your
web application you have to buy a
license so moving on so in our code now
let us go to SCP here is it put it over
here okay hmm
so right now our website here it is um
pretty typical website we do have this
nav bar we haven't actually made the nav
bar do anything I was
you guys the example of our navbar and
then we've got some text in here cool so
now what we want to do is we want to
have a graph page so like let's say we
wanted to add in a graph so we go over
to our init dot pi here and we'll come
down and now we're going to do is we're
going to say at app dot root and we're
going to add the root to be graph
underscore example so that's our app
root now our graph example of pull this
up here I'm just going to copy and paste
something from my previous code and I'll
just explain what the code is so I just
don't want to type all this out so copy
this and we'll come down to here and
we'll say define graph examiner score
example and from here I'll paste so
what's happening here first of all we
don't actually have any of the other
documents up so this will make a little
bit more sense soon but we set up the
chart ID right now we're just passing
through literally like chart ID has the
ID for the chart you can play that later
on it's not like a huge thing you can
probably just always leave that chart
type line you can put line scatter fill
area all kinds of stuff and then I've
got a chart height dimension this is how
high the chart is you can also set how
wide the chart is I usually choose not
to because if you don't it will just fit
it'll just take up the max it can and I
prefer to do that so it's kind of
dynamic then we get a sample data set um
you can feed through just about anything
JSON so you just convert whatever you
want to JSON now dataset it's already
kind of in a JSON format so you don't
actually have to convert it to a JSON or
anything it's just it'll be it's legible
the only thing I will add is
surprisingly I don't think this is
actually a unix or JavaScript time so
this won't won't come out how I intended
actually I don't think but anyway we'll
talk about that a little bit
then I'm passing through page type per
page type parameter which is we're
calling it a graph
so we can use that with an if statement
in our index.html and now we actually
define chart and then series graph title
all that well I'm going to loop back to
this in a moment because you'll
understand this a little bit more once
we do some of the other necessities here
so we've got that added this one for
sure if I don't have there should be a
link to the sample code in the
description of the video if there is not
someone holler at me because this is
absolutely necessary that you have the
code on this one I don't want anybody
have to type out all this so that's your
index dot pi and now what we need to do
is we want to head over to our static
folder and we want to make an addition
to that so let's go here come into
static and we'll do file new and this
one we're going to call graph dot J s
over here and in here we're going to
copy and paste some of the document for
graph J s and this is basically
basically was going to do is pass these
variables through our high charts so and
with the ID here which will always be
chart ID but that's what we're going to
do so that's going to pass through and
it's going to pass through basically
these these variables and so this is
just a quick JavaScript functionality to
pass these variables through our actual
heist hi sharks
module thing so once you have graphs J s
that's all set and now we really just
have one more thing I believe and that
is to edit our actual template here so
index.html
bring index over here cool so this is
our current index.html so now we can do
is there's a couple of things first of
all we don't necessarily have to have an
if statement because the chart will just
fail if we don't have the proper data so
first let me just add the chart
information and then we'll we'll loop in
the if statement that way if something
goes wrong with the if statement we know
it's if same and not the chart so nice
thing I want to do is copy and paste our
chart code um so that's going to be this
code right here I'm just going to copy
that and basically um you can put it
just below this if statement here so I'm
just going to paste that's there okay
and now I'm going to explain this code
here let me shift this over to us gonna
borrow me oh never mind I guess I can
anyway so we've got the div tag this is
the div tag basically for our actual
chart and then we have the script that
basically underneath it that defines
those variables that we were just
talking about so these variables are
being passed through just for
explanation I see I'm actually using
this code on c of BTC but we can change
this to be a colon slash slash Harrison
Kingsley comm and H Kingsley I'll just
put that so those are credits this is
like the bottom right stuff so this like
here where it says hi charts that's what
the credits are series is the data that
you're passing through colors is the
order of colors of lines so as you draw
the lines like the first line that's
drawn or the first data set that's drawn
it'll be this color then this one and so
on and then a loop loop back title title
the chart x-axis information y-axis
information chart information and then
finally subtitle which is like a
subtitle here the axes um there's all
kinds of stuff you can do with those
axes you can make multiple axes you can
do
due dates obviously you don't have to do
dates you could do multiple y-axis
multiple x axis and you can add even
like groups to your axes a lot of lot of
customization that you can do and
everything's possible within here you
just need to change your variables
basically but maybe if I get enough
requests I'll do it like a little bit
more in-depth c.height I'm not a little
confused why our height is 100 pixels we
definitely want it to be a hundred
pixels tall I'm gonna go and change that
to 500 for now I don't think that's
gonna matter cuz I think it gets ends up
getting edited here here in the chart
data but yeah so we'll do that and this
should be just fine it goes imma static
and then graph J s which is what we just
added so everything should be good we'll
save that and let me go let's go check
our index our init page here index.html
okay so our / graphic sample and I'm
sure I'm forgetting something but let's
just go to the website here let's go
ahead and also restart Apache fresh of
course okay so we get an internal server
error Oh come back to here and the
question is why are we getting an
internal server error probably because
we don't have a slash logger that's what
we couldn't guess let's try this again
yep okay so just in case someone missed
that we're getting an internal server
error because I was I said the route was
just graph example it needs to be slash
graphic
so everything else appears to work let's
check the about page really quick before
we move on so about this site well I
mean okay now let's go ahead and head to
graph underscore example and here we
have our lovely graph so this is indeed
500 by 500 now what if
chart height there if we go over here
and we get rid of the width parameter
sure why that was over there so get rid
of the width parameter let's go ahead
and restart one more time and I have too
many windows open right now
LEDs are fresh much better I like this
one and you if you understand how to use
div tags you can specify how big like
the maximum size of your div that you
want to be so you could have like two
charts right and then like if you'll see
here like we can stretch this chart out
or we can bring it in and so it'll take
up as much space as you let it basically
yeah so this is gonna be it says jan 17
but I think this is a like Jan 17th of
like 1969 or whatever um so with just a
quick aside about the data here so
obviously it is plotting in date time
but I'm I'm guessing this is not the
what I wasn't intending so in JavaScript
time JavaScript time is like UNIX time
times a thousand so so keep that in mind
so this data is probably no good you
would need to add three more zeros to it
to be like aligned where you expect it
um so that's it with graphing oh I guess
I'll show you guys the if statement just
to be certain because if without the a
statement like let's go back here I'm
guessing in the source code will have at
least yes so see if you look in the
source we're pulling you know like the
colors that we were passing through but
we don't have any chart information but
we're still doing all these script
loading and stuff I mean if we don't
have to do that we don't want to do that
so let's see if we can't real quick add
a if statement here so we did I believe
passed through yes we pass through page
type equals graph and we did pass it
through here so then we can come over to
our script and basically ask here if
page tight equals graph then we do that
and then otherwise we can end the if
statement
and if like that so now let's go ahead
and refresh this and we'll come back
over here here's some Kinsley comments
dear oh okay so that's our I thought we
did and if I'm looking oh gosh
okay so we're treating it like it was a
variable there let's save that it's
refreshing all the time it's interesting
did I have whoa I'm not even sure how
that ish how that they'll have if
statement around that's weird
oh I'm confused how the air popped up
that coming so I don't have even the bug
I don't know anyway no questions asked
how that air showed up but anyway so now
we can come down here we can see that
you know now we're not wasting time
importing wasting processing to memory
all that importing scripts that we don't
need and then what we can do is we can
go to slash RAF underscore example and
there's our graph and now we've actually
done the import that we need so so
that's that um like I said there's a lot
of customization you can do you can do
multiple axes both x and y you can do
multiple lines you can do 3d charts you
can do all kind of like line scatter
area fill all that stuff bar charts all
kinds of stuff so I don't know if you
guys if you guys want to see more of hi
charts with flask let me know I just
mostly just wanted to show an example of
a JavaScript plug-in that we can kind we
can use and kind of manipulate through
Python and pass data through with Python
but you should be able to do this with
all kinds of JavaScript stuff so I just
want to show that real quick other than
that we're going to go back to flask and
do a few more things with in flask
there's a lot of built-in functionality
of flask things like flash and URL for
that we've saw it sort of show the URL
for all so let's go ahead and build up
this navbar a little bit
oh this stuff like that kind of ran out
the website a little bit just cover all
the basics of flask but anyway if you
guys have any questions or comments on
this video feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time